tu es sûr de ton plein parce qu il est
pas loin quand il s'est quand même c'est
bon à tout son matos on a toutes les
infos on a plus bienvenu on peut le
relâcher non faut que j'y retourne
on n'en sait pas encore assez à quoi ça
sert d'avoir une raide on n'a jamais
réussi à régler une seule caméra va
falloir qu'on se remettre au travail
ah oui lui quel que soit le boîtier
qu'il utilise l'image est toujours
parfaite cinématiques épique biro lui
qu'à mes couilles en ski nautique menti
alors tu prends ton henriette
et en voiture simone
c'est moi qui conduis c'est toi qui
klaxonnent
faut que tu expliques encore
[Musique]
alors françois je t'ai dit qu'on n'avait
pas fini toi et moi tes vidéos youtube
l'image d'un envoi du lourd à chaque
fois je suis sûr que tu as des réglages
secret comment tu fais
françois se voit sortir aller et
fonça n'ont même pas pour un petit café
on
mais ya pas de réglage secret faut juste
bien cadré bien exposé bien exposé ça a
l'air facile pour toi
bah non juste bien géré est en train
d'exposition le triangle d'exposition tu
m'as pris pour une buse
c'est la base le truc de débutants ça
peut pas être ça ton secret enfin la
base la base je suis sûr qu'en cherchant
bien on va trouver le truc que tu sais
pas c'est pas juste des réglages et une
intention derrière
ouais le triangle d'exposition c'est la
base ok mais elle n'est pas toujours
bien comprise surtout en vidéo faisant
les trois composantes essentielles de la
vidéo et de la photo même si on n
utilise pas exactement de la même
manière dans chacun des dix ce qu'il
faut pas oublier c'est que la
photographie ça veut littéralement dire
écrire avec de la lumière dans ces trois
composantes qui vont te permettre de
sculpter ton image
il y à l'ouverture la vitesse
d'obturation et la sensibilité
ces trois facteurs vont influer les uns
sur les autres et c'est tout un art de
savoir les utiliser ensemble
et vu que chacun de ces paramètres va
influer sur l'exposition de ton image
quand on modifiait faut modifier les
autres faut gérer les trois en même
temps tu veux dire que le mode
automatique c'est pas une bonne idée
ah non pas en vidéo la limite les modes
semi automatique dans certaines
situations bien particulières
mais le mode auto tu shootes en mode
auto non
bon je te donne mon secret mais après tu
me laisse partir dit toujours on reprend
depuis le début klaus pas si évident
même quand on a l'expérience
on va commencer par l'ouverture dans une
optique qu'il a bien sûr la partie
verrerie mais il ya aussi ce qu'on
appelle le diaphragme qui est un système
qui va permettre de faire rentrer plus
ou moins de lumière dans le capteur de
ta caméra en fonction des conditions
lumineuses on va donc pouvoir ajuster
mais son usage principal c'est de
déterminer la profondeur de champ
c'est-à-dire la zone net dans l'image on
donne le degré d'ouverture avec la
lettre f suivi d'un nombre plus ce
nombre est petit que l'ouverture est
grande par exemple f24 ou f-18
c'est grand et l 22 ces minuscules une
faible ouverture donne une zone est très
grande
al'inverse une grande ouverture donne
beaucoup de foot d'arrière ou d'avant
plan
et une zone est très réduite on peut
observer ce qu'on appelle aussi les
faits beaucoup à le bloquer un classique
du cinéma
ah ok d'accord ça fait en tout cas pas
vu un film toi contrairement à ce qu'on
pense souvent beaucoup de flou d'arrière
plan ne donne pas forcément un look
cinéma y a qu'à voir le nombre de scènes
cultes de grands films dans lequel il
n'y a strictement aucun flou dans le
flou d'arrière ou d'avant-plan c'est
avant tout du langage par l'image
bon ok des convois et petit halo de
lumière c'est satisfaisant c'est
esthétique mais ça va surtout dirigé
l'oeil du spectateur perd ce qui est
nette et contribuer à raconter
l'histoire on peut choisir de donner du
contexte à notre image avec une grande
profondeur ou alors de se focaliser sur
un personnage un objet ça peut même
cachet aussi certaines choses aux
spectateurs et là encore ça sert à
raconter une histoire
dans cet extrait de the revenant par
exemple l'arrière-plan et net
tout simplement parce que le real a
voulu mettre son sujet en contexte seul
face à l'immensité de la nature dans cet
autre extrait par contre l'arrière plan
est flou parce que ce qu'on veut c'est
que le spectateur regarde le visage du
personnage ses émotions parce qu'ils
lantourne
ok ok rue comme on fait avec les ciseaux
les six ont les ciseaux les ciseaux les
iso les ciseaux les iso les silos les
iso les ciseaux les iso les ciseaux les
iso les ciseaux les ciseaux les iso les
ciseaux les iso des ciseaux à les iso
his own way et 6 où les iso ou plutôt la
sensibilité iso c'est la deuxième
composante du triangle d'exposition pour
faire simple elle sert à dire à notre
capteur je veux que tu sois plus ou
moins sensibles à la lumière
plus on monte les iso plus l'image sera
clair plus on les baisse plus à l'est
sont bons écoute moi bien le françois
dans ma carrière j'en ai connu des
appareils qui montent à plus de 400
milles iso parfait on peut finir dans la
nuit avec st à oui c'est sûr institut
veux que ton animal ressemble à un bol
de semoule bah oui mais ça serait trop
beau plus tu montes tu es 10 au plus
l'image est clair mais une contrepartie
plus on monte les iso plus on aura ce
qu'on appelle du bruit numérique et le
bruit numérique ses traits disgracieux
à titre de comparaison c'est comme le
souffle qu'on peut entendre quand on
fait une prise de son on peut le
rattraper en post prod un petit peu avec
ce qu'on appelle un des nos leaders mais
ça reste une forte dégradation de
l'image
certaines caméras ont d'ailleurs une ou
plusieurs plage iso qu'on appelle native
et en gros tu filmes avec cette
sensibilité iso et point barre ce qui ne
garantit une image sans bruit mais qui
peut te contraindre à utiliser un filtre
end et peut être essayer encore de
m'embrouiller n'enfile trend est un
filtre à densité neutre situé dans une
situation de forte luminosité et que je
gardais temps fou de mouvement et tombe
ok il faut trouver un moyen de diminuer
l'apport de lumière sur ton capteurs
pour ça il ya les filtres end et c'est
tout simplement un verre teinté qui va
agir comme des lunettes de soleil sur
ton capteurs et permettre d'exposer
correctement il en existe des fixes et
des variables mais attention aux
variables même s'ils sont très pratiques
ça peut vignes été échangé un petit peu
la colorimétrie et pour cette histoire
de bruit faut pas confondre le grain et
le bruit comme au cinéma
oui le grain c'est cette texture qu'on
retrouve sur les films tournés sur
pellicule parce qu'ils étaient loin
d'être lisse niveau image comme au
cinéma
oui oui d'ailleurs aujourd'hui on
rajoute du grain numérique pour donner
un look organique proche de la pellicule
à nos fichiers numériques comme au
cinéma
[Musique]
et la vitesse d'obturation
la vitesse d'obturation c'est tout
simplement le temps d'exposition à la
lumière qu'on va donner aux capteurs
pour chaque image qu'il va capter
généralement sur les boîtiers photos qui
font de la vidéo elle est exprimée en
fractions une fraction de seconde par
exemple le plus souvent si on filme à
une cadence de 25 images par seconde on
définit une vitesse d'un 50e 2 secondes
pour le temps d'exposition de chaque
image plus longtemps on laisse exploser
plus il ya de lumière et donc plus
l'image sera clair al'inverse une
vitesse d'obturation rapide entraînera
une image plus sombre mais en vidéo la
vitesse d'obturation a un rôle bien
spécifique celui de faire apparaître ou
pas du fou de mouvement le fait d'avoir
ce flou de mouvement donne une image
plus naturels car notre oeil perçoit les
images cette façon quand ça va vite on
observe du flou mais d'un autre côté une
bonne scène de baston à la marvel ça va
souvent très vite et le réalisateur
utilise dans ce cas une plus grande
vitesse d'obturation ou alors comme dans
il faut sauver le soldat ryan de steven
spielberg une vitesse d'obturation
utilisée pour obtenir le côté cisaillé
et net de ce film de guerre ça aussi un
impact sur l'effet de flics goring où le
sentiment que peuvent générer certaines
lumières artificielles mais la plupart
du temps ça sert la narration
donc ces réglages c'est aussi comme au
cinéma oui oui enfin non sur les caméras
de cinéma on parle en angle d'obturation
mais c'est la même chose
la terminologie et d'être juste de
l'époque où les obturateurs c'était des
disques rotatifs avec un trou plus ou
moins grand mais toute façon il ya un
moment où on règle le plus pur des
contraintes techniques mais dans un
objectif de narration on règle pas pour
compenser trop ou pas assez de lumière
règles pour raconter une histoire mais
c'est quoi ton délire tu veux faire un
film
[Musique]
dis-lui non dits lui non
10 le nom d'îles et non
non non non
[Musique]
je veux faire
non
il lui
si lui n'en arrive au kg
la rive
il arrive